so after President Trump said he's
replacing VA secretary David Shulkin
Shulkin penned a farewell in The New
York Times which was angry justifiably
so he made the place better he served
his country and no one likes to be fired
I should know three times but I got one
beef he claims he was fired because he
opposed privatizing the bureaucracy
claiming the private sector couldn't
handle these types of patients but how
do we know that the difference between
public and private is what enabled the
VA tragedy in the first place the
difference was accountability in the
free market there are consequences to
actions if you suck you suffer you go
out of business in the public sector
there's often no real costs to your
blunders which is why when things are
bad it takes years to fix them like the
VA but where there is accountability
there are standards if you want evidence
look around you you live in the greatest
country the world's ever seen and it's
one built on competition which rewards
the competent and punishes its opposite
the market works faster in eradicating
problems because it can't put up with
them jokin did a good job but he did a
good job after a really bad job by a
bureaucracy immune to competitive
pressure by bashing privatization
without any proof
choking defense a system that's not as
good as he is so maybe let's try a new
approach if it doesn't work at least the
free market won't try to hide it so Dana
I think choking did do a good job but he
was starting at less than zero at the VA
which mean it's like taking like let's
say you become coach of an O & 16 NFL
team and you get it two three and
thirteen for some fans you're a hero
yeah yeah so I think this is a very
complex problem it's been going on for
decades actually and then actually they
even the disagreements between the
Department of Defense and the VA like no
presidents been able to I bring them
together and get them to solve their
differences this question about
privatization it always sounds very
alarming except for when you think about
a veteran who might live in a rural
community and doesn't have access to an
immediately near hospital VA hospital
should they be allowed to have then a
private voucher to go and get treatment
at the nearest hospital to them rather
than having to travel so far or what it
happens a lot is they forgo treatment
right and so that they're left alone so
I do think that innovation has been
stymied at the Department for decades I
actually think that he was not let go
because of performance at the department
as much as it was questionable ethical
behavior in regards to being in the news
for things that are unpleasant to be in
the news about that he handled
afterwards but the trips overseas with
the wife and all that it was just
getting to be too much to bear mm-hmm
well what do you think about that that a
day it says about innovation I think
within public agencies when you don't
have accountability innovation is slowed
and also just accountability in general
prevents quality from coming to the fore
do you agree it's something in some way
shape or form yeah well I mean I I think
what you say is true I mean the private
sector tends to be more punishing for
failure yeah but it but what I think
we're overlooking here is and Dana
touched on this this is not a new debate
privatization has been a long-term
discussion with regard to how we treat
our veterans in terms of their medical
needs and what's come up in the debate
and relieve me it's been a full-throated
to be is that gee you know oftentimes
veterans are suffering from things like
post-traumatic stress and trauma combat
trauma or they're having brain injuries
of a type that are only suffered on the
battle feeling alike and that the VA had
developed specializations and even
innovations and how you handle these
issues and that the private sector did
not have it and did not have an
incentive because there's how many such
situations do you see in ordinary life
and by the way Dana and with regard to
people who live in rural areas distant
from VA hospitals they already give out
vouchers and so forth so what you have
now though is a situation according to
shokan and some of the reporting that
I've seen this morning that where
President Trump is of a mind that there
needs to be privatization he doesn't
want to hear about the argument he
doesn't want to hear about the debate so
Shulkin writes in his op-ed hey this is
not an honest conversation this is about
pursuing a political agenda and he notes
by the way great high levels of right
now approval from veterans for the VA I
think he said 70 percent yeah and but to
can't believe my point to that was that
it was so bad when he took it over that
any improvement would be taken his
welcome relief yeah absolutely because
it was just abysmal in terms of the
abuses that were happening and it's
still a very serious problem that they
have with the VA and you know vadym are
all taking it over now is really gonna
have you know a tough time because there
are so many abuses there there's
corruption it's very difficult to
terminate anybody for a lack of
competence and whatnot and so he's going
to be struck with sort of trying to
rebuild and rehabilitate the culture at
the VA but with you know an earnest
heart and a firm hand he should be able
to do that and if he wins the confidence
of the people there hopefully they will
be emboldened and passionate about it to
help the veterans because they really do
deserve our very best
Jesse last word make it count okay I
would say that cabinet secretary is
never going to be able to fully control
a bureaucracy they can only seek to tame
it and in terms of Shulkin he did an
average job so you have a lot of good
things that happen where they have the
accountability and whistleblower
protection act so you can fire and
discipline yeah bad apples within the VA
and then also as one said they expanded
the mental health care for veterans
returning overseas that were predisposed
to suicide but the ethical lapses were
troubling I mean he's taking his wife on
a European sightseeing and shopping tour
then lied about it had to reimburse six
figures the privatization thing yeah of
course that's an argument but I look at
this last year last March the Inspector
General found that the VA was still
lying about wait times that they were
saying there's actually a 36% rate that
veterans had to wait longer than a month
they lied and said it was only 10% and
then so about 13,000 in Virginia got the
choice program as you said you get to go
to a private hospital and they never let
them go to the private hospital and they
had to wait three months to go to the
private hospital so that's last March
yeah this March
same thing the audit found the same
thing they're fudging the numbers on the
wait lines I think that had a lot to do
with it too
all right there you go